have been kind of in the forefront of
dealing with a lot of this racial
inequality was
warning us about is don't just do it
when it's a hot topic to make it you
look bad exactly continue this battle
like continue to to work in your
community have these conversations and
i'll be honest with you the people that
i saw that are in my periphery circle
that aren't really friends but i kind of
know of them that were just in
everybody's face screaming this [ __ ]
kind of condemning people
i don't see any of that [ __ ] or not that
they should have done in five four three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast i'm
your host david so we are my co-host
here for today we have ed
park edric park aka n2
also
the the head honcho at secret society
it's a very lengthy introduction that's
the longest that's how [ __ ] rappers
do it man all right you know what it is
aka this aka
always dude yo i've been watching a
bunch of these [ __ ] hood videos dog
i've never seen so many people have so
many aliases
it's crazy it's like
it's like yo man like straight up homie
you feel me like look look i dropped out
of school when i was like [ __ ] three
bro like i ain't [ __ ] do nothing you
feel me i haven't done nothing hey let
me tell you right now you know what it
is it's your boy dicey aka shoots aka
crap killer aka your [ __ ] babies
daddy's mommy's babies daddy aka
defeating killer aka spider arms aka
long ankles damn dog what are we calling
you man it's like bro you couldn't
[ __ ] memorize a school book but you
sure as [ __ ] got this thing down that's
just crazy
those [ __ ] hood videos their favorite
phrase is you feel me yeah constantly no
no no it's you feel me and now i'm
saying yeah and i'm saying no i'm saying
i used to get so much [ __ ] about that
when i started doing jk news years ago
i had no idea how many times i said you
know what i'm saying you feel me you
know what i'm saying it's just it's just
a part of speech you know when you're
growing up well in certain areas in
certain areas yeah yeah i just couldn't
i just i didn't know how often i said it
yeah yeah and there's a lot of things
even when i first started this podcast
like the pacing in which i spoke how i
told stories everything improved over
time and you just never know these
things because you're not listening to
yourself speaking but when you're on a
podcast all you have is a person in
front of you in conversation and that's
it you gotta listen back on it man i
remember when i recorded my first song
ever and i listened back to it i was
like that's how i [ __ ] sound like i i
got i cringed and i died inside bro yeah
i was like that's how i [ __ ] sound
and everyone was like dude you got a
good voice man like it sounds good on
the track but to me here in the back i
was like oh my god everybody has those
moments yeah yeah but then that's what
i'm saying like i recognized certain
things that i needed to fix as well not
the voice thing but like certain things
of like yeah enunciation like clarity
and all of that [ __ ] have you ever
watched those videos where they go
around and they interview people from
different like hoods and games yeah dude
one of the most funny ones that i saw
yeah and i'm not
making fun of this game yeah i'm only
talking about what i saw in the video in
case i go here and then people just
start yo i heard you was saying this
[ __ ] about me
like i don't want any of that [ __ ] i'm
just saying about what i saw in the
video i just want to clarify this but it
was a hawaiian [ __ ] gang
and just that alone made people [ __ ]
roast the [ __ ] out of this guy in this
video have you guys seen this [ __ ] if
you just look up like hawaiian crips
they're in hawaii they're hawaiian crips
in hawaii wow i didn't know there were
crips in hawaii yeah i didn't know you
could gangbang in paradise yeah like i i
don't see that happening right once
again yeah i am not making fun of the
situation
right i'm simply stating what other
people said no you're gonna get shot by
a machete on site when you get to the
library it's crazy because these dudes
they're so i mean albeit they might
scrap they might do some dirt yeah but
because they're hawaiian the way they
speak it's so calming yeah it's like hey
bro you know we out here you know you
don't want to [ __ ] with us bro i'm like
damn this boy man his [ __ ] voice is
stupid as [ __ ] he's going to beat my ass
to a lullaby
but people were just [ __ ] roasting
the [ __ ] out of these like local
hawaiians too they're like what the [ __ ]
this guy is a dishwasher at my dad's
restaurant and there's other people are
saying would you do a [ __ ] drive-by
coconutty
oh my god dad these people can't catch a
[ __ ] break yeah i had no idea they
had like gangs like that in hawaii well
maybe it's just one of those things
where
like an ex-gang member or a gang member
relocated to hawaii and then started you
know because that does happen right like
people do start gangs in other cities
other countries
from they used to be a gang member at a
different place that's what happened to
uh what's it called ms-13 yeah yeah el
salvador right yeah that's a
transnational gang you know and it's
crazy because ms-13 started in los
angeles right and then those people who
were doing gang [ __ ] and violent stuff
and they were killing and murdering
people they got deported back home and
then they started the gang back home but
it was a gang that started here yeah
yeah dude when i was so here's the
funniest [ __ ] so i used to live out in
k-town as you guys know but the very
specific spot that i lived lived on was
a street called hoover right
i was watching gang land
and ms-13 popped up i was like oh what a
what a
what an interesting dock and i wanted to
watch this gang right because it's a
it's a gang i didn't hear about until i
moved to l.a and you realize you're
living in their territory i am and so
funniest [ __ ] ever right the guys it's
they're doing the whole voice over yeah
ms-13 blah blah started in los angeles
something something something hoover
street i'm like hoover street
and then i see they do that scene where
they're driving by and then you look at
the street that they're on yeah it's
literally my house that i live in is in
there
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
what is this yeah right and they're
going into this whole thing of like if
you see these like food stands on the
corner
you know nobody really [ __ ] with them
because emma is under the ms-13
protection that's what they're saying on
the show yeah and so you'll see a bunch
of gang members usually kind of scoping
around because they'll take their their
their cut from their money say oh you're
allowed to be here don't worry we got
you yeah so it's kind of some gang [ __ ]
extortion type of stuff but at the same
time nobody's gonna [ __ ] with them right
so i guess it kind of makes sense i mean
i live in ms-13 territory isn't that
crazy like i so
this is i had no idea so i'm talking
about late at night 12 o'clock one
o'clock this is 7 11 i would just walk
there yeah like what we used to we used
to
yeah walked there and then after i saw
that gang land documentary like nope
there was a street dog spot i used to
get straight dogs there yeah all the
time yeah yeah all the time yeah i would
go up and i'm like oh my god i know
those toast those tattoos on that guy's
face now yeah he's an ms13 game member
yeah and it was the same guy that would
just be around there because i think
he's looking at the hot dog stand make
sure nobody [ __ ] with her or whatever
but cause there was there was this club
across from the street that i used to
call medusa yeah yeah
that that club is so ratchet bro that
club is hella ratchet hella ms-13 and
then i started noticing all the gang
tags yeah i'm like oh holy [ __ ] i have
just been walking out and flip-flops and
socks eating these hot dogs around these
gang members i had no idea yeah but
that's the thing though like if if you
don't look like trouble i mean chances
are they're not can usually they're not
petty thugs like that i mean yeah you
can run into those type of people too
who maybe don't like asians too much you
know and you just caught at the wrong
time but generally in those spots like
you're not really going to experience
trump i think it's a part of being kind
of street smart too you know what i mean
like you're not going to go around and
act a fool or do something like unusual
in an area where you feel like yeah you
got to just kind of keep it cool you
know what i mean i just i'm pretty sure
they're not going to [ __ ] with me dude i
gave that woman half my bank account
if anything else i sent that woman's
kids to college yeah i ate so much dogs
like how many hot dogs do you want yeah
quattro
[Laughter]
no no no no senor
[Laughter]
a lot of hot dogs poor favorite
poor favor
[Laughter]
gracias
this is just like i speak english
oh [ __ ] why don't you say so oh my god
struggling my ass off
um
did you uh hear about the uh
the people involved in the elijah mccain
you know what elijah mccain is no who's
that so during the whole uh obviously
you know blm and all the rights and
stuff like that and you know the
uncovering of a lot of the police
brutality that was happening on the
black american community there was a
young kid named elijah mccain who was
walking home either from a liquor store
i believe oh yeah yeah of course of
course yeah yeah the one who was wearing
the hoodie yeah yeah yeah then you know
super sweet kids with that smile yeah
i guess uh they're getting chopped i
don't know his last name elijah's yeah i
just knew him as that i guess the the
medics and also the police involved
aren't getting charged for like murder
or like negligence or something like
that but it's it's it finally happened
so it's you know it's kind of crazy man
because i remember when that happened
you know out of all the stories that i
heard obviously george floyd and
everybody else you know
it was a very like tumultuous time for
us
um but elijah mccain's story is the one
that kind of got me the for sure man
because you saw that video of like how
he interacts with his peers and his like
co-workers how sweet the kid looks yeah
maybe maybe he has some sort of i don't
know if he was like uh suffering from
some sort of disease i think it was i
think it was like uh i i don't want to
say i don't want to misspeak yeah but he
has some like you know he was like
slightly odd on the spectrum he was on
the spectrum for sure yeah and just like
the way that he was communicating but
even him wearing the whole uh face mask
was because his skin was really
sensitive right it was as cold as [ __ ]
oh okay yeah it was as cold as hell
which was pretty common for people to
wear masks yeah yeah and it was cold as
hell yeah so um but yeah even seeing not
only like during his living days but
like his last moments too with i think
it was what three individuals three cops
right banging yeah yeah hearing the
audio right and um it's super sad super
[ __ ] sad because he just looked like
the type of kid who would brighten up a
room you know what i mean like there's
just certain people man when when you
know you feel that energy and they flash
that smile it brightens up your day
i didn't know the kid personally but he
seemed like one of those types i guess
like when he was taken down they
injected him with something to calm him
down like right right like the amount
was ridiculous right because he was
throwing up and everything too yeah yeah
like the way they had him down and then
i think like the damning thing about it
was after that whole thing
either it was
those cops or other cops that came
throughout the site that he passed away
they were taking selfies right right
right right which blew my [ __ ] mind
dude i was like yo this kid just [ __ ]
died are you insane yeah what are you
what are you memorializing there even if
it wasn't let's say if it was somebody
who was drugged out the fact that you
would sit there and mock it and
celebrate somebody's death blew my
[ __ ] mind right nev i've
like you know we hear stories about
police brutality or whatever right and
let's just say i'm gonna play devil's
advocate yeah and we don't know what's
happening on their jobs we don't know
the type of erratic human beings that
they see
even if that a human life is lost and
you go to somebody's basically it's like
their grave site and you take a photo
and you smile ingest of it like what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do about it insane to
me yeah blew my [ __ ] mind it just
kind of shows you
just the complete disregard for life
that some of these people have yeah you
know and and like yeah when it's a race
thing it's even worse but sometimes it's
just disregard for life in general and
these are these are people who supposed
to protect life uphold the law you know
and
here you are like you said mocking the
death of a of a [ __ ] kid man it's
weird when i saw that [ __ ] like i
remember it it just reminded me a little
bit of myself and also reminded me of
just about those weird kids you know who
i think like socially they were really
odd but they were very very [ __ ]
sweet and like
if you could imagine like this guy who
probably already like socially might be
a social pariah like a lot of people
don't understand him yeah and he's going
home people are coming and telling him
to stop he doesn't know what's going on
yeah and he [ __ ] dies for being weird
i know man i know and you know during
it's uh good that you bring up this the
the whole thing again because like
you know we had talked about it
extensively on the podcast during the
whole time right and for me it got to
the point man where
i i just had to disconnect from it
because like
it was just so much [ __ ] in succession
one after another you know and it was
just so disheartening and like so
mentally tact emotionally mentally
taxing
uh and
you know too i was going through my own
personal [ __ ] at the time so
i was like man
i'm trying to like bring more awareness
about it talk about it you know
really like stay up to date about it but
when it got to the point where i was
like all right this is too much i just
need to disconnect from everything you
know the the mental break that i needed
was from
i think like during this time because
i was doing all these videos for it
right yeah yeah and i don't think a lot
of people understood i didn't write any
of this
right that was literally off the cuff
and it got to a point where everybody
was dming me
can you do a video on this can you do it
can you curse this person now can you do
this
but people don't understand too like
social media because of the way it's
designed and how people feed off of it
and how that how people expect certain
content to hit
it
nobody thinks about the content creator
and how much it eats away at us right
like
this is not stuff i did for cloud like i
didn't care about the like people oh
like you you know you gain like 50k
who the [ __ ] cares yeah who cares man
like we're talking about [ __ ] that's
actually needs to be talked about that
needs to be brought to you know his
attention people in the periphery of my
circle yeah you know these people aren't
close to my circle right but they're
like bro you're killing it on social
media it's like is that what you think i
give a [ __ ] about you piece of [ __ ] but
that
you're talking about i'm killing it in
social media people are getting killed
bro literally man what the [ __ ] you
talking about man i think that was like
the hard part like where i uh i started
thinking
it really got me to a point where i
started thinking about
how much
this this engine
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or getting in the way of your
goals my friends this could possibly be
you i have been using betterhelp for
quite a while now and you know i love
having them as a sponsor because it's
something that i use consistently yes
you can get your own licensed
professional therapist and you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it is
professional therapy done securely
online so for those of you out there
that feel weird going into a place guess
what try better help do it in the
comfort of your home and if you don't
like the therapist that you're messed up
with the first time you can go ahead and
switch out and find somebody else that
matches with you and by the way people
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available visit betterhelp.com genius
that's better help and join over the 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health so special offer for
genius brain listeners get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com genius how much the
engine of like social media runs through
people wanting to be recognized so hard
yeah every app now is developed and
feeding off of people's
want to be desired right i need to be a
hot commodity if like i always say this
all the time
you know there's so many people on
instagram you don't have to you know you
don't have to do trends right you know
you don't have to try to do comedy
you don't have to do these things
but you know people there's like this
endorphin rush that you get from when
somebody looks at you they value you by
this point system right he goes guess
what the value of yourself is now this
number
because you have 300 likes this is who
you are oh i guess you're somebody
important maybe i should hang out with
this person yeah now now we get to see
actual metrics in which the way people
value somebody's life right which is
what black mirror [ __ ] right exactly
was so scary because of how realistic it
was and people don't even see the
parallels
yeah man and and and what's scarier is
like that's the trajectory too right
because sometimes black mirror would
kind of like elaborate on certain things
that are happening right now to like
what it could evolve into and so
it's it's
really really sad sometimes when you see
the current kind of landscape of society
and culture uh
especially because of technology i
wonder what happened though it's like um
[Music]
here's like a really great understanding
and once again too like i'm i'm not
saying that people should be beating the
same drum
constantly but you know one of the
biggest criticisms of or critiques of
this movement right with the blm thing
was
once it stops becoming popular i wonder
if people are still going to be
cognizant of this inequality that we see
in this country yeah doing stuff in
order to make it better yeah right
because when it was hot it was hot yeah
people were approaching people
in in my personal opinion not in the
most like
conductive way
yelling at them berating them or you
know even if not that let's say if it's
in a possibly having conversations about
you know the the the cultural barriers
that you know the black community is
going through i haven't heard much about
it um as of late yeah um even though
it's stuff that's probably still
happening
and oh for sure it's happening yeah yeah
for sure it's happening yeah it's still
happening yeah and i think like a lot of
what a lot of people who
have been kind of in the forefront of
dealing with a lot of this racial
inequality was warning us about is don't
just do it when it's a hot topic to make
it you look better exactly continue this
battle like continue to to work in your
community have these conversations and
i'll be honest with you the the people
that i saw that are in my periphery
circle that aren't really friends but i
kind of know of them that were just in
everybody's face screaming this [ __ ]
kind of condemning people
[ __ ] i don't see any of that [ __ ] or not
that they should have done that in the
first place but you know i don't see
that same fervor i don't even see any of
this stuff like
i wonder
makes me wonder how genuine people were
about it right and i'm saying too like
yeah i did those videos and i'm still
about that community outreach i still
have these conversations i just wonder
now if people are still doing it right
i'm not making a judgment i'm just i'm
just wondering no definitely not as much
as
when it was hot when it was on trend you
know
um and i think definitely during that
time there were a lot of people who
jumped on the bandwagon because it was
the trend because they didn't want to be
left behind or left out
they want that fomo they didn't want the
fomo you know they definitely felt i
think people also almost felt pressured
to do it and if you didn't you were a
piece of [ __ ] right because the hottest
word was allyship oh if you're not an
ally go [ __ ] yourself right which by the
way for me i didn't really agree with
because sometimes
one of the phrases that i hate the most
and i used to hear this [ __ ] growing up
and i didn't even agree with it when i
was younger when i was a kid was oh it's
better to say something than nothing at
all i completely disagree if you're an
idiot you should shut the [ __ ] up just
keep that mouth shut yeah you keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut and you stay in that
corner because you're the village idiot
and nobody wants to hear what the
[ __ ] village idiot has to say
i think a better saying is like if you
don't know shut up and listen
so
people just
were kind of
i don't want to say force but they felt
the social pressure to say something
about stuff that they didn't really care
about or not absolutely absolutely um
and
look i i
i can't really speak on the whole
feeling of peer pressure with that
because i didn't speak about it because
of peer pressure you know it's something
that i really genuinely cared about
right
and it's not that i don't care about it
now you know but like i told you for me
it got to the point where
i recognized that my mental health was
in tatters and i needed to work on
myself first and foremost
i can't help anybody if i can't help
myself you know
um so it was a process for me of like
just kind of disconnecting from things
and really just trying to work on myself
and build myself back up but yeah now
now that we're here and we're revisiting
that conversation too
it's
definitely happening it's not a maybe
you know
again it's just that it's not as popular
or trendy to talk about it and be about
it anymore yeah um
but look man within saying that
exactly why i am also grateful and
thankful for the life and position that
i'm in because
what we're talking about when it comes
to things like this these people who are
getting murdered who are being uh
unfairly profiled or or just being like
uh criticized or you know just hassled
or harassed
they don't have these types of freedoms
and liberties that
people should have yeah right they're
god-given freedom and liberties they're
american freedom and liberties and so
for me to even have the ability to be
like i need to disconnect from all of
this [ __ ] to work on myself
i'm [ __ ] grateful to be able to say
that and do that because some of these
people can't be like i need to
disconnect myself from all this travesty
they can't
that's that that's not their choice yeah
this [ __ ] is a part of their life every
single day no matter what they do they
can't change that because of the system
the way it's stacked against some of
these people and minorities right yeah
so when i talk about those things too i
say that with being very grateful for my
situation and that's why it's even more
important too because everybody should
be able to have that you know
you shouldn't only be able to have that
if you're of a certain class or
ethnicity or you know
you have a certain profession or you
live in a certain age like
none of those [ __ ] matter we're all
just human beings at the end of the day
and everybody should be treated with
decency common decency fairness with
their freedoms and liberties intact but
truth of the matter is that's not the
case you know it was hard to i think um
what a lot of people found out and i
think it was just it was a fast crash
course
for number one um
how manipulative media can be right and
i think we've always heard it we've
always heard about like the manipulation
of media and like what they can do to
change the narrative of these stories
absolutely but because of how easily
accessible knowledge is now or the news
anybody can be a news reporter yeah
anybody can write something up and it
can be considered truth whether it's
real or not like even when people listen
to this podcast like i always say too if
i say something that i feel like is
factual and it's not an opinion you
should definitely double check what i
say because i you know i may have heard
it in passing maybe i misread something
yeah just take it with a grain of salt
exactly i think that's one thing too
before you you continue my bad but um
you bring that up is like i think people
seem to have this expectation when
they're listening to this type of uh
media right that
we're like a [ __ ] encyclopedia or
something we're not yeah we're just
human beings we're having a conversation
we're gonna misspeak sometimes we're
gonna get the facts mixed up sometimes
but that's why did what just dave just
said right now is like that's why it's
important for you guys to fact check and
and if we misspeak or say something get
something twisted that's completely okay
for you guys to fact check this on that
yeah but don't take our word and our
opinion and our thoughts as gospel and
the truth like it's gonna be mixed up
sometimes but that's what we do as human
beings we make mistakes
i've definitely seen like throughout
this whole pandemic because you know
all the stuff that i've i've been
looking at um i never really paid
attention to right so for example if i
could think of a really good one was
like the presidential debates yeah one
of the things that i've never really i
never really cared about presidential
debates before i actually never gave a
[ __ ] but because of how great of a job
or how bad of a job media was at shoving
like the whole trump agenda in my face
and the whole biden thing happening i
just i couldn't stop watching it made me
want to watch
sleepy joe was one of the funniest
[ __ ] disses hands down you can say
what you want about trump this one was a
fire ass bars they called him sleepy joe
you got bars bro dude
let me tell you something that bar still
raised that [ __ ] is falling
asleep all the time
uh sleepy joe is hilarious man yeah i i
think a lot of people too now are
getting into this um
are kind of shoving
uh
a lot of [ __ ] into like liberal
faces
because of what they condemned trump for
they're not putting that same type of
heat on to biden right once again i
don't know too much about politics right
um all i know is that i've definitely
seen biden on the verge of falling
asleep multiple times as he's speaking
which is concerning for me he's very
concerned he's like visibly aging in
real time yeah
he looks like the [ __ ] keeper
holy [ __ ] from tales from the crib yeah
but but at least the [ __ ] keeper had a
little more energy in him oh the [ __ ]
keeper had a lot of spunk he had a lot
of energy i don't know what the [ __ ]
he's saying sometimes i mean that was
obviously the concern from the start of
like dude this guy's too old he's too
old but it was it was pick your poison
situation you know what i mean it was
like
for somebody like me anyway i can't
speak for anybody else i voted for biden
yeah but that's because there's no way i
wanted to see another [ __ ] four years
of this buffoon trump you know and
look people can say what they want about
you know their political agenda i i i
don't identify with a political party i
don't identify as a democrat or
republican or libertarian or whatever
i it's just in that circumstance i was
like enough is enough man there's
there's a certain
decorum and in a way that a a president
should
handle himself or herself with
and this guy was not it do you feel like
that i mean this is what people are
saying right is the trade-off worth it
right could you have dealt with an
[ __ ] for four more years for somebody
who's coherent versus somebody
who well you know also too with like
biden like he is
i think from what i'm seeing from what
his criticisms are
or what his critiques are anyways is
like
just how liberal he is specifically with
his policies
um
you know obviously one of the biggest
flack that he's getting now is the the
pull out of afghanistan how it was done
and how it was done also too there's
conversation i'm not sure about you guys
have to fact check me on this but uh
people were talking about how he wants
to do another stimulus check like
another
extending the unemployment no no he was
pretty firm on that i don't know if
there have been new conversations in the
past week yeah but he was pretty firm on
yeah it's going to end september 4th and
there's not going to be any more
extension you're talking about like the
the bonuses for the unemployment right
the extra money they were giving for the
kovid no yeah he was pretty firm on that
and actually some states had even ended
it before the september 4th end date and
there's like lawsuits in in some of
these states because of that yeah it's
interesting right it was
this pandemic has been a crazy social
experiment for people oh yeah right one
of the one of the biggest social
experiments and i you know i'm curious
to hear about what people think about
this is that there was this idea that
listen if you give people money to cover
their bases for their livings they're
actually going to either a work harder
because they're they're they're
the the foundation for what they need in
life is already covered so they don't
have to worry about other things which
is andrew yang's biggest thing right was
like yo let's give them everybody a
thousand dollars a month so it covers up
these bills yeah and then they can go
focus on more important things sadly
enough that did not happen
people took this money they chose not to
work
and they spent it on a lot of stupid
[ __ ] yeah which you know but also that's
what stimulates the economy right that's
how you kind of get back because we had
that dip in march because of when the
pandemic really hit the fan and so part
of like yeah giving this extra money was
to put it back into the economy and
stimulate that kind of kind of but it
doesn't work at the other end too
because people still need to work in
order to create products i know i know
we had to deal with it with the clothing
i know i know man it affected it
disrupted not just like domestically but
like the supply chain internationally if
you guys notice too if you guys cook out
there have you guys noticed how
expensive [ __ ] beef is bro not just
be everything everything is everything
is [ __ ] expensive my grocery bills is
ridiculous yeah i might as well just go
[ __ ] out to eat now dude what the
hell is this [ __ ] starting my own
farm bro yeah i'm like holy [ __ ] dude i
was like thinking about cooking up
steaks i'm like nah i'm just going to
buy it yeah man the cost of everything's
going up and a lot of these like before
we continue my lovely people let's keep
this podcast beautifully sponsored with
daily harvest this is the song that they
have daily harvest
yummy food in your belly and your
freezer or your stomachs
that is not their song but i'm gonna
wait for approval anyways guys for this
time of the year it usually means
getting back into busier schedules and
you know
i love food but when i'm swamped and i'm
thinking about what's for lunch let
alone actually finding time to grocery
shop it's damn near impossible and
thanks to daily harvest my freezer is
always stocked with delicious options
that are ready in minutes daily harvest
delivers delicious harvest bowls
flatbread smoothies a whole bunch more
organic fruits vegetables right to your
door and you know your boy is about the
health but also i can't do the health
unless i'm talking about the flavor and
that's what daily harvest has it
literally takes minutes to prepare and
it never uses preservatives added sugar
or artificial anything so enjoy this
time of year even more like i do with
daily harvest go to dailyharvest.com
get up to 40 off your first box yes
that's
dailyharvest.combrain for up to 40 off
your first box dailyharvest.com
brain places in for example the
restaurant industry right lack of
workers and so they're always short
staffed because yeah a lot of them work
making more money collecting
unemployment than they would of working
the job so
what person what sane person would be
like well you know i'm gonna
go back to work where i make half of
what i'm making right now off
unemployment yeah you can talk about
like whole ethical thing or you know but
let's be real man if people are
struggling if people are barely making
ends meet they're going to take a little
bit of [ __ ] whatever they can to make
life just a bit easier 100 yeah
but yeah it was just kind of like weird
where
people would be [ __ ] lazy man
that is just what it is like we're all
so [ __ ] lazy
we're so [ __ ] like even something
small too like
i made so many goals in pandemic
i've i've executed none of it i've
literally executed absolutely none of it
i was like dude you know what's gonna
happen your boy gonna have a six-pack
he's gonna be oh you made those type of
guys and then i was like dude i'm gonna
write three films
none of it happened yeah absolutely
nothing i actually took the time to just
to take a break yeah
well no but but i think that was uh very
helpful to some people too right like
people who are just generally like
busybody and like exhausted yeah take
take just check off the the the
checklist of things that they want to
accomplish right and
it's just move move move doo doo doo and
then just having this period to like
okay just slow down for a minute let's
kind of reprioritize things that matter
do you really that does this really
matter for you to accomplish and you
dedicate this much time and energy to or
should you be dedicating more of that
channeling more of that to maybe like
your friendships that you may have
neglected you know whatever you think
about a lot actually wasn't actually i
mean it's kind of morbid but it's like
my parents death
like what in what way i i didn't see my
parents almost two years
right uh-huh and then when you go back i
went back home recently yeah i'm like
[ __ ] they aged again right okay two
years right you just the last time two
years yeah they aged again yeah after
two years yeah and you know when i'm
younger two years is nothing
when you when you see your parents at
the time when you're super young my mom
had me when she was kind of late like 35
and i'm what 10 years old she's 45 45 to
47 you don't see much change yeah no now
you do though you do when you see from
uh 67 to 69 right it's noticeable it's
[ __ ] noticeable man and they're at
the la they're at the last part of the
race the last leg of the race that was
one of the things that pissed me off the
most too because like losing time with
my family i mean harder for you to see
them more regularly but then my parents
is they're like a 40 minute drive away
can't see them yeah and i can't see them
and yet we have all of these
[ __ ]
like not even being able to agree on
wearing masks yeah at the thick of it
i'm like are you [ __ ] serious like
these are the [ __ ] that i need
to make sacrifices for need to be more
careful need to not go out need to do
all this [ __ ] to like make sure that i'm
responsible and not not a throwing fire
on it yeah or i mean throwing gas on the
fire
yet
[ __ ] like that are just going
out trying to [ __ ] live their lives
as if there's no pandemic going on
prolonging us getting over the hill and
more and more are taking away from [ __ ]
that i want to invest my time and energy
into that are important to me yeah and
that would really [ __ ] like brew
inside of me and i would get pissed off
i'm like man well yeah i mean once the
vaccine came out it made it a little
more comfortable to be around yeah yeah
for sure just kind of making sure we
take the right steps to make sure that
we don't have before we go and see our
parents yeah which is something that was
really good and comforting you know
because you know my parents are getting
older and i think like watching them age
was something that i didn't really
expect when you're young you just go by
and you live your life you don't really
think about the aging process and death
is not something that's really just at
your doorstep yeah so you're not
consciously really thinking about it you
think mommy and daddy are going to be
around forever you think you're going to
live forever even though you know about
death you know you're going to die but
it's not really at like the the front of
your mind yeah right and then you know
when i went back recently i looked at my
mom and dad i'm like [ __ ] they got a
little older yeah and i think you know
you bring that up is a good reminder of
just like people
internalizing their own their own
mortality is like bro we don't know
if
we're going to wake up tomorrow and have
a chance to live another day nobody can
tell you with certainty 100 certainty
yes i am going to wake up tomorrow when
i go to sleep tonight and have another
day to live
most likely you can say that but that's
the best you can say so when you
recognize that fact that you don't ever
know when your time is
your time could be today it could be 10
years from now it could be 50 years from
now whatever the case is you don't know
and when you internalize that you truly
truly internalize that i feel like it
should spark a little something in you
to have a little bit more purpose in
what you do and what you think about and
what you invest your time and energy
into and look
i've tried to like always keep myself on
check with that too but it's hard you
know what i mean like you can't always
be thinking every day like oh yeah you
know i got to be
grateful death is something i said like
my personal death doesn't scare me but
people i care about dying scares me
like the idea of not being able to see
my parents is something that i don't
really think about i even try not to
think about it sometimes right because
but but the sad thing is you can't
control that you don't know when people
are going to exactly it's something that
is just
you can you can't control and it's very
hard to let go i know man and and that's
why it's
on us really if we're the ones realizing
that maybe our parents aren't thinking
that so it then it's on me to like
really act on that and really cherish
the times that i have with them and
yeah try to do more with them as much as
i can um but going back to the whole not
being afraid to die thing i can relate
but i'll tell you what i had a dream
where i got shot in the chest and i was
dying
that fear is something different
like
i always thought i'm not scared of dying
either but in that moment
like i basically got into some [ __ ] with
somebody they just pulled out a gun put
it on my chest and shot i just collapsed
and i was just leaning up against the
wall and i could see like
the the white
closing in yeah you know and i'm like oh
[ __ ] i'm dying this is the end
there was a feeling of
i'm not ready
you know like
yeah i recognize that i'm dying right
now but i'm not ready i don't want this
and so
i think it's a little bit different to
be in that moment i mean that's the
closest i can relate to of what it feels
like to be dying you know but yeah i'm
just bringing that up because i always
felt the same way that i'm not ever
scared to die when it's my time it's my
time i'm gonna go
but when you're recognizing that you're
dying versus yeah if it's your neck
snaps and you're dead you're dead you're
not going to have any thought about it
but if you recognize that you're dying
and your life is slipping away
yeah man that was a really really
unsettling feeling i had a homie who
recently his parents just passed away
and it's crazy when you see the the type
of soul bonds that people create this is
like conversation about is that is an
afterlife real or not for a lot of
people who don't believe in like a
savior they don't believe in um
just a spirit or a soul in general yeah
we just think that we're sentient beings
and we pass away one of the things that
i see too is like
that makes me not believe or makes me
believe that we do have something inside
of us like a spirit or a soul is when um
like my friend whose parents passed away
so his father passed away first
and then quickly after when you
typically see a partner who has been
around somebody for they've been
together for 40 50 plus years
the other person follows soon after
right nothing wrong with them physically
yeah like everything in the health
checks out yeah their will to live
disappears right and then they just pass
away which always
is it's crazy like i told my i told my
parents like you know who has to die
first right i was like oppa has to go
first
because
our mom has us like she'll she'll be
able to you know look at us and thrive i
was like dad you [ __ ] you're [ __ ] out
of luck
you're not gonna get comfort for us yeah
you robot yeah you know
his best friend is my mom yeah you know
he's confident on everything my mom goes
first he's [ __ ] yeah he's going to go
soon after his will to live is going to
disappear yeah and that's like that that
thought is even crazy to me too it is
that's [ __ ] wild man imagine this too
like just this thought it's like one day
there's going to be a point where you
can't eat your mom's food even when
she's alive because she won't be able to
make it because she's so old yeah that's
a weird thought to me too because that's
my mom's love language as weird as that
is to us though it's another thing that
should serve as a reminder to even be
thankful that we have a mom to have
possibly that feeling of longing for you
know when when they're gone some people
don't even have that in their life right
[ __ ] losers
i'm kidding
no i'm kidding i'm just i just feel bad
but yeah man it's that's what i'm saying
of like how easy it is to just take
things for granted it's like yeah we
talk about it like as a matter of fact
that we even have a mom and when the
time comes that maybe they leave this
earth that yeah we're going to think
about not even being able to taste their
food anymore whatever but there are some
people man who've never even experienced
that maybe they're lucky they don't have
to you can't miss what you don't have
baby
that warmth from a mother yeah you never
had that how lucky dude
now you're a serial killer but it's all
good yeah nobody ever cared for you
you're [ __ ] lucky dude like nobody
you can't miss what you never
experienced no no heartbreak for you man
yeah i like something small too when i
went back home like my mom
uh she was
blinking like really hard like this
right i'm like what's wrong
right and she was like oh like my my
eyes are bothering me and i'm like
okay
how come you didn't do anything about
yeah like what are you doing yeah and
she's like oh i'm just using these eye
drops i'm looking these eye drops are
like [ __ ] these shitty ass eye drops
i'm like it's like expired eye drops
yeah it's like where did you get this
right she was like
my doctor said i could use whatever
that's fine and i'm like looking at my
dad i'm like you're not gonna use this
[ __ ] [ __ ] in her eyes what are you
doing man she just had cataract surgery
i know like what the [ __ ] is this and
it's like and then i start to think like
if they were younger would they have
made this mistake or is it just because
they're older now like this is like
stuff that they don't really care what
is it a mistake or just complacency you
know what i mean yeah like the feeling
that i get because when i see stuff like
that too first of all like the ailments
that
your parents are living with at this
point in their life right it's just
another [ __ ] problem comes up you
know
and it's just like for you you're like
why aren't you guys taking better care
of yourself you should be doing this you
should be doing that
for example my dad he's diabetic right
he shouldn't be eating [ __ ] like white
rice you know he's eating white rice
though oh absolutely he's eating white
rice he shouldn't be eating [ __ ] like
bread and like sweets but he [ __ ]
eats and i'm like pops you got to take
better care of yourself what are you
doing you know he knows he knows it's
not a mistake but it's just like
i like it you know like when i come home
after a hard day's worth of work i just
want to eat some rice is that so bad
yeah like it is for your [ __ ]
longevity
do you want to be alive what's wrong
you're a diabetic [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are you talking about what is this
nonsense yeah but my dad's hella funny
dude my dad's like pre-diabetic right i
come back home
i see [ __ ] pastries eighty-five what
i'm saying everywhere bro that's what
i'm saying like hey
what is this he goes oh i got these for
you i'm like this looks like it's been
around for a while
like i don't know what
i don't know what the hell but this is
the weird part where the child starts to
become the parent right and i'm like are
you [ __ ] are you
both face lying to me i will [ __ ] you up
what do you want to say take off your
[ __ ]
he's like i don't even eat this stuff i
[ __ ] you not 30 minutes later i take a
shower and come back out this
[ __ ] got a croissant
this little
eating croissant i'm like
what the [ __ ] did you just say he goes
it's a little after dinner snack i'm
like
what in the [ __ ] are you talking about i
know man and it's frustrating and it's
exactly right bro i find myself
lecturing my parents more now that at
this stage than they lecture me and i
just you know for me
i just want them to take better care of
themselves because it's like simple like
on this last weekend trip or two
weekends ago when i had dinner with him
i was talking to my mom like hey mom you
know you should definitely go out for
more walks you know just keep your body
like busy and active i'm not saying like
go into a full workout regimen just just
do basic stuff you know just to keep
your body like fluid or whatever
um
and she's like oh you know i like yeah i
go for walks and so i'm like yeah but
eating too you're gonna you gotta watch
your diet like and then i just um i
thought i thought to myself man i'm
sitting here lecturing them about how to
take care of the same conversation too
with them dude i saw my dad's [ __ ]
fat ass belly and [ __ ] pre-diabetic [ __ ]
and this guy over here i'm like having
this cop dude i'm talking about this
[ __ ] dude yeah late at night
right he goes i'm like he has a fat
sweet tooth he loves ice cream i love
ice cream beans like me man yeah we're
like ice cream lovers right
ice cream that sounds gay as hell but we
love ice cream we're ice cream lover
boys
and he goes i don't even eat ice cream
anymore look into the freezer three
buckets of ice cream
i'm like what are you talking about what
is this are you are you just acting like
you have dementia right now to piss me
off he goes i just have a little bit
every night i'm like
i thought you said there's a big
difference between i don't eat it at all
and then it's becoming i have a little
bit every night i'm about to just sock
him in the stomach dude and i'm like
what are you saying right now dude
and so he goes i he goes i already had
my ice cream earlier i'm not gonna eat
any more ice cream bro
i should you [ __ ] not i come outside
the room 2 a.m in the morning i see him
he's a 2 a.m ice cream eater oh my
goodness
yeah
walking yeah into the fridge yeah
opening up the fridge sitting down
eating ice cream oh my god what's he
doing up at 2am and you tell me bro
eating ice cream
he woke up from for an ice cream break
oh my oh so he went to sleep he wasn't
up like yes i think he was asleep eating
ice cream wow i was like what the [ __ ]
okay that's another i'm looking at this
fool i'm like
what are you doing he goes he's really
hot i just need some ice cream i'm like
you oh you [ __ ] dude i'm gonna
beat your ass dude this fool keeps lying
to me i was like you lied to me one more
[ __ ] is it is it the korean ice cream
though or is it like the haagen-dazs
it's like no it's like a gallon of
[ __ ] like haagen-dazs ice cream
it's not even like the korean bars it's
like the one that you have to scoop out
he's not even putting into a bowl this
fat ass
dude
that's that's another level bro i've
never heard of somebody waking up mid
sleep and it's like i need some ice
cream right now loves ice cream yeah i
thought my mom she gained weight my dad
was like dude getting away to your
guys's age is not a good look yeah it's
like yeah you could be a little thicker
because i heard it's like it's healthier
you know for them or something like that
i'm not sure some doctor correct me but
yeah i was talking to my mom on the
phone the other day and i'm like hey i
saw you know dad's belly and you guys
gained a lot of weight as i make sure
that you guys be careful about stuff
that you eat she goes the doctor says
i'm perfect
let me tell you something [ __ ] your
doctor
you're lying to me hello what doctor
what doctor yeah you [ __ ] let me get
the name of this doctor you name a
number yeah
i want to talk to him
he says i'm perfectly healthy i was like
what the [ __ ] doctor kang who is he
he's always a korean guy
or some korean guy yeah eat three
gallons of onion juice yeah and then
stretch in the morning and then you'll
live another 30 years exactly this
[ __ ] whiskey the whole ginger and
you're good
[ __ ] dude yeah but just dealing with
this [ __ ] it's like oh my god we're
we're becoming the parent dude yeah and
it's because
again going back to the whole mortality
thing it's that we recognize dude my our
parents time on this earth is is more
likely more limited than than you know
extended and i just want to be able to
spend as much time as i can with them in
good health them in relatively good
health and and also having their mental
faculties too right because once this
goes it doesn't matter how much healthy
everything is well that's what i'm
saying they have to do it by fixing
their diet and kind of being very
conscious about
like mentally fixing themselves and i
don't know if it's like a part
i don't know if they just don't care or
what it is but
you know once once i move them over here
to los angeles i'm gonna be on their ass
yeah
you just [ __ ] hound them that's why
their life is over you just wait till
you [ __ ] move yourself so your
parents are gonna come to l.a at some
point they have to yeah because we all
live here right i can't i can't watch uh
after them yeah yeah they're probably
going to retire next year okay and then
they're going to live there for another
couple years and then i'm moving their
old asses here dude at least at least
you'll have more face time with them and
yeah yeah because i need a babysitter
but that's the thing bro no matter how
much you get on their ass about it i i
truly believe it's just more of
complacency at this point they're just
like ah [ __ ] it you watch me put a
camera in their house though i'm
watching them
that's just creepy man i don't give a
[ __ ] they're too old to [ __ ] anyways
dude what they're gonna
[ __ ] old ass [ __ ]
i'm watching them well guys that wraps
up this episode of the genius great
podcast
the watcher
i'm gonna watch my parents
everything dude i have them on the
speaker what are you doing put that
cheeseburger down [ __ ] sleep eating
ice cream you
like
what the hell
but uh you guys can catch the genius
podcast every thursdays and sundays you
can catch ed ed too and make sure you
check out scrt society for your [ __ ]
wonderful fashion basics yes sir and we
got the new new on the way so stay tuned
for that i'm really excited about it
check it out we'll see y'all next time
peace